I'm Donnie flood I don't know why but
I'm doing the zoom wave
I guess I'm just used to doing the zoom
wave now
um
thanks for coming I know this is like
the last session before Kelsey Hightower
so excited to get you guys through this
last one hopefully leave you with some
excitement this is the first public talk
that I've given anyone's given on live
UJS so excited and eager to get your
feedback we've got a lot to get through
so
let's get started I'm going to do some
demos I'm going to show some code
there's definitely code on here that you
may not be able to see in the far back
you may want to move up closer to look
at code feel free to sit back there but
uh just a fair warning
um so real quick what is live VJs it is
a open source typescript framework for
live view applications in node.js in
Dino
doesn't mean much right now why did I
build it
uh
basically over the last two years uh you
know like a lot of you I've done a lot
of single page application development
feeling you know fairly disappointed
with how that's how that's gone so
I I uh you know submitted the talk a
little spicy title The Calling this the
anti-single page app framework it's not
really that I'm more excited about live
views than I am disappointed in single
page applications but hey spicy spicy
titles get uh you know get accepted so
quick overview of like you know some
challenges that I think face the single
page application uh kind of ecosystem
this is not an exhaustive list but some
things that I've run into
first we've got you know two stacks that
you have to build
if you're building a single page
application right I'm not talking about
a static site but an application where
you want to send data back and forth
you've got to build your front-end
application react view spell name your
your front and app and you also have to
build a backend application something
rest API graphql something else right so
all of a sudden you've got two stacks
and now you have to connect them so the
context switching is really costly
language you might have to switch
languages you might be writing obviously
in the front-end JavaScript something
else in the back end
and there's just a bunch of
communications to figure out between the
front and the back end now you can hire
full stack developers I claim to be a
full stack developer myself
and those people can navigate these
challenges but they really can't solve
this disconnection between the front and
the back end
also
I think single page applications turn
into really complicated code a lot of
the time so I think the spaghetti
coefficient is monotonically increasing
oftentimes that in the spa applications
I've seen everything being one page
actually causes a lot of complexity
challenges that you have to to face
there's a lot of client State Management
challenges to overcome State
synchronization again between the front
end and the back end is very hard can be
slow hard to optimize
um and then you know a lot of Frameworks
are shipping kind of where where
batteries are sold separately right so I
think I think about this as normal
things are hard so form validation is
hard you have to find some form
validation framework out there learn it
maybe it's not maintained next month who
knows submissions are hard file uploads
you know kind of Choose Your Own
Adventure find something out there
hopefully it works you might get
previews you might not drag and drop as
hard
and then hard things that you want to
add to hard features you want to add so
real time multiplayer stuff like that
become really difficult
um so those are some of the problems
I've run into again not exhaustive lists
maybe you've you guys have had an
amazing time with single page
applications
and you know so struggling with things
for a bit and then one day I got a
message I'm on a slack with some friends
kind of my from my friend Larry who's
actually up here thanks Larry
um eventually started watching this talk
this video series on Phoenix live view I
had no idea with Phoenix love you I've
heard you know I've been hurrying some
some mentions of live view out there
said it was pretty cool I should check
it out so you know with someone you
respect tells you if you're watching
videos I went and checked it out
and honestly I was blown away Phoenix
live view
is really impressive I was super excited
very inspired
it just solves a lot of these problems
where you have these two distinct back
ends or two distinct Stacks you bring
those two things together
and what Phoenix live view really kind
of made me understand is you could
create single page app like user
experiences
with the ease of server-side rendered
HTML
I know that sounds weird but that's what
that's what it is and so I got super
inspired
and I started you know learning about
live view I started going through the
demos watching the videos writing some
code uh and and these are some of the
advantages that I think live the live
view Paradigm kind of brings to uh
front-end sort of software development
first of all you got one stack so it's
there's no worrying about connecting the
front end and back end there's no rest
or graphql API that you must build
you're actually just writing one kind of
API that connects to the front end and
back connects the front end to the back
end and serves serves your live view
there's no State synchronization
challenges there's only one place the
state is that's on your server and it
pushes client updates uh we'll get to
that in a minute
um
you know the so the inverse I think of
this Getty coefficient is the pizza
coefficient
which means it is easier to
compartmentalize the code that you're
developing so each live view is its
owned own server route and its own sort
of like set of apis that you're
implementing so it's a really small API
we'll show you that as well in a minute
super small super powerful very well
defined
and then live view ships with a bunch of
batteries included features that you
know make normal things easy and
actually hard things easy as well so
again form validation right form
submission mapping kind of data models
between back and forth between forms and
your data is really easy file uploads
with things like image previews Pro like
automatic progress drag and drop
constraints all those things become easy
as well
and the hard things are easy so
optimizing the size of the packets that
are going back and forth between your
server and browser already done for you
the real-time multiplayer features are
also you know you want to add chat you
want to add presents you want to add you
know updates on one page get reflected
automatically on another all those
things are easy and I'll show you some
of that stuff
so that's why I got excited about live
view
there was just one little problem which
was it was written in elixir
and that's no dig on Elixir it's a
really cool language super amazing VM it
runs on top of the erlang VM
I just happen to really like typescript
and
I didn't want to write I didn't want to
learn erlang I didn't want to write
erlang the other thing is that from an
ecosystem standpoint
erlang you know this is based on like
this stack Overflow survey erling is
popular with about two percent of
developers while you know obviously
JavaScript typescript is popular well
maybe obviously is popular with about 65
percent of developers so there's about
30 times the Developers
who are doing typescript and JavaScript
in compared to compared to elixir
and I was you know again more inspired
probably by Phoenix love you than uh
upset about you know the spa Frameworks
and I wanted to bring this live view
concept to the JavaScript ecosystem
so
as I was you know kind of learning
Phoenix came to me that live view is
actually a protocol so it's it's not it
doesn't have to be limited to The Elixir
ecosystem
in a sense they're you know really clear
messages that go from the client to the
server it's just Json events get pushed
up the server you know runs through the
the state kind of machine we'll show you
that in a minute
and then sends back diffs to the client
the client applies those diffs so it's
pretty it's actually a pretty
disconnected uh client and you know
front-end back-end kind of protocol
and so what I thought to myself was we
could actually write Live use in
typescript theoretically
um
and so that's how I nerd snipe myself
into writing live BJs
uh I do think that might have been
Larry's plan the whole time but
well we'll have to ask him over drinks
later
um real quick I do also want to give
credit to the live view team like I
would not be here without them uh the
concept of live view came directly out
of the Phoenix live view ecosystem uh
you know the reference I I consider the
reference implementation of live view to
be the Elixir implementation there's no
real spec
and we are we actually used the Phoenix
live view client JavaScript to run live
VJs so there's actually we didn't want
to invent the wheel we're built on top
of this battle tested productionalized
production ready like tens of thousands
of production apps are running the same
front-end JavaScript that we are
so again I wouldn't be here without
without the Chris McCord and the Phoenix
team I don't know any of them if anybody
anybody here knows them would love an
intro but um
I just wanted to give credit where
credit is due
okay so talked I've talked a lot we
haven't seen a lot of yet so what is a
live view
uh real quick it is a server rendered
HTML page that connects to the server
over a persistent websocket
the client automatically listens for
user events send those events to the
server server routes those events to the
live view
runs the lifecycle methods we'll show
you that in a minute recalculates The
View and then sends optimized diffs back
to the client the client automatically
applies those disks to the Dom
and that's that's sort of how it works
live view JS makes that entire most of
the the complex parts of that
um just transparent to the developer so
you have to write your live view and
then the live vhjs framework
automatically routes your events
automatically hand you know handles
rendering your methods calling the
lifecycle functions automatically sends
the disks back automatically calculates
the diffs so it makes kind of writing
the again these you know Spa like user
experiences super straightforward for
the developer
cool let's see some livius
uh this is going to be a little awkward
because I got to look over here to the
right but um all right so here's a live
view we've got a little toggle button
we're going to toggle between you know
text and emojis pretty straightforward
nothing you know super crazy
uh all right we got a counter here
classic canonical like example where you
hit some buttons some numbers are
updated
uh let's see what else we got
we got a live dashboard so this
dashboard just updates every second it's
kind of random data but you know this is
super straightforward in live view live
ejs
um so it's just generating some code
automatically saying that that data to
this to the client here's a little
search example
so I happen to live in Denver
so this is just uh whoops
some
a Denver ZIP code that you can look up
uh you know a store a set of stores so
that's a live view as well so all of
this is happening
um
all right yeah let's close these this is
a little awkward part sorry guys
okay
um
oh shoot
and that's when I lost my
speaker notes
all right
and we're back sorry about that
okay
so you got to see some live views there
now let's take a look at some of the
code so you saw this example hello world
this is when you know if you're in the
back and you can't see the code feel
free to move up
this is like the super basic live view
example right we've got three methods
defined here that are part of your live
view we've got a mount method which is
called when the HTTP request first
happens and when the socket connects and
re-renders
we've got a handle event method which
basically takes your click event in
updates the context of your live view
which is the state and then we've got a
render method which takes the contacts
renders an HTML page and that's how you
implement just that toggle view that you
saw before
[Music]
so pretty straightforward and again this
is like what you write as a developer so
you don't have to think about connecting
to the websock you don't think about
your rendering diffing applying that
diff to the Dom this is your uh just
this is the the code you'd write for
that example
next counter example similar right
method layout we've got Mount handle
event and render in this case we've got
a couple of different events that are
going one's called increment one's
called decrement but overall it's the
same kind of model right you render your
your HTML in that HTML there are events
that are defined by the bindings PHX
click one for decrement one for
increment those events get routed back
to your live view update the context
re-render all that stuff
so as I mentioned
live view all live view JS and live
views all run on the server so zero
percent of the code that you just saw
was shipped to the server the only thing
that was shipped to the server was the
HTML that was rendered
uh and that's it and diffs that are
happening as your as the user is
interacting with with that HTML
so again super you know this is
obviously oversimplified but the way it
works is the client watches for events
once you've annotated your HTML with
those bindings it'll list automatically
listen for click events other events
send those events to the server live VJs
automatically knows where to Route those
events what what live view to Route it
to automatically runs the lifecycle
methods Mount handle events some other
methods you'll see in a minute uh
calculate you know passes that to render
render re you know re-renders the Page
live VJs takes the diffs or takes the
render Compares it to the last render
calculates the disks ships those back to
the client client applies that again all
transparent to you as a developer
um
all right we're gonna we're gonna try to
do this uh we'll see how this goes but I
think it'd be cool
to show you
uh just the discs real quick
uh so let's see here
all right
so
this is this is the socket traffic
that's coming back and forth between
live view JS and the browser so you can
see our count is zero now our Count's
one you can see the message coming back
and forth and this right here is
actually the data coming back from the
server and you can you can see I don't
know if you can see that very well in
the back but basically what you're
seeing is inside this diff Json response
it's basically saying I'm I really just
want to set that number two or that
where that value was a one previously
I'm just going to set it to a two now so
I know that's a little hard to see
probably from the back I just wanted to
point out that's that's sort of like the
amount of data that's coming back it's
just saying I've got to apply this diff
to this part of the HTML tree and the
client automatically knows how to apply
that to the tree
um
let's look at
the dashboard is a little more fun
to look at
here we go sorry it's a little awkward
Network page again
all right let's lower that down so you
can kind of see at least
um
all right so now you're seeing kind of
in the bottom there
every second you're getting a new diff
come by and that's that's only updating
uh yeah there we go you can see at least
a couple of these pieces of data
so you can see you know this diff is
coming it's only changing the values for
a couple of different parts of the tree
and those are just automatically being
applied by the
by the client
so that's a little bit there's a lot
more that goes into that but just wanted
to show you guys uh the disc coming back
and forth
all right so again your live view lives
on the server you don't it doesn't ever
get pushed the client all we're pushing
is is deaths which is pretty cool
um anatomy of a live view so there's
only five functions in a live view that
you need to worry about when you're a
developer there's we'll go over these in
a little bit more detail but Mount which
is called on initial rendering on the HD
on the HTTP request and when your
websocket connects
and that just basically used to
initialize and configure your live view
renders we talked about this one just
you need to Output some HTML live VJs
takes care of doing the diff and kind of
passing it back
um and then there's three different
handle methods and we'll go through each
one of these you saw handle events that
one handles any user events that come in
from the browser and there's a couple
more handle info and handle params which
we'll I'll show you some some examples
in a minute
um so we've talked about Mount
live VJs calls this automatically called
once per cycle for you know live view
load once on the HTTP request and
launching the websocket connection
it really just initializes the contacts
um and any what's cool about this is any
HTTP session data is actually
automatically pushed to your live view
so in the mount function you get all the
data for that user's session
um so that's how we actually actually
transition data from your HTTP session
to the live view itself
um
so yeah there's there's actually quite a
bit of detail on livevjs.com if you're
interested more in the like life cycle
of I'm not going to get too much into
life cycle of Live use but there's a
bunch of sequence diagrams and and
content on livevjs.com if you want to
check that out
uh we talked about render again real
quick uh automatically called by live
VJs passed it's past the latest state or
context of your live view so after all
those handle functions are called you
always get the latest context in your
render and your job is to render your
HTML page it also passes some kind of
metadata with it some
csrf token paid the current page URL
some other helpers help helpers that
you'll see in a bit and it does not
uh send back
any HTML
the live view live view JS takes care of
sending only diffs back
slight correction on HTTP it obviously
Center sends back HTML but everything on
the website could only sends deaths we
talked we saw handle event a couple
times as well so
um you know user events on the on the
client side are routed here
automatically typically you're updating
the contacts based on these events and
otherwise you know reacting to the data
passed into the user events
um okay this one we haven't seen yet you
know I'll show you a demo of this in a
minute but there's another Handler here
called handle params and so this is
called anytime the URL changes for your
live view so uh and and also call it on
the initial page load so if you have a
URL coming in that has some query params
on it for example this is uh
automatically called again by the by the
framework and allows you to update your
contacts based on any URL parameters or
any hashtags or whatever whatever part
of the URL you want to process
um cool let's look at some examples here
so we've got two examples this is so
right now you can see we've got no URL
params this is just like an example Food
Bank donations app we're just gonna
sort here by clicking on the the column
you can see it added some params here
and you know sorted by ID our our list
of items let's sort by days until
expires you can see we've got you know a
bunch of stuff that are going to expire
in the next day or so and again that all
that was happening just by changing the
URLs the Euro the page URL and the query
params in the page
uh the other one we have here
is just a kind of a I don't know maybe a
Tab demo right where we've got these
different buttons or tabs you click on
them you can see the ID in the URL is
changing you may not be able to see that
in the back sorry but basically we're
setting different IDs on the URL and the
pages being re-rendered automatically
based on that
so that's what
I close these sorry
all right so those are some handle
params live view examples uh you know
just to like go over the server code
real quick
we're looking at the handles for him
functions called when the URL changed
and what's passed into that function is
is a URL right a
and what we're able to do in this case
we on line four we pull the search for
the ID search param out of the URL
we look up the server and then we update
the context using the socket data
science with that server the rest of the
render Loop runs sends the diffs back
and your page gets rendered
so pretty straightforward handle info is
actually a really powerful function
um and this is the last we've covered
everything else as the last one number
five I know it's a big big API to learn
but this is where server-side events
actually get sent to your live view so
server-side events happen in really a
couple of different ways one is you can
have another function called send info
which is on the socket so saka.send info
and pass an event to that function
directly it's a good way to offload any
asynchronous requests that you want to
make so let's say you get a click on the
user or search for example in the handle
events life lifecycle method you that
you can call socket.send info and send
that event over to handle info continue
through through rendering maybe load a
you know loading screen or something and
then run that search method
when that returns update the socket and
then the rest of the render happens the
second other way second way to get or
send them sorry handle info is called is
typically through Pub sub messages
so I'll show you some of that in a bit
but basically you can built into live
view JS our Pub sub uh methods so you
can subscribe to any topic you want and
when you subscribe to that topic those
messages that are sent to that topic get
get sent to your handle info callback
um and so that's a good way to you know
we'll talk about this later but real
time multiplayer uh kind of features are
are usually driven through this handle
info uh Pub sub uh methodology
cool all right
Let's uh we saw the sales dashboard one
so just to you know here's like how that
works
we've got
you know just showing you two methods
here we got the mount method and in this
case we have on line five we've got this
kind of helper function that just
repeats a function and an interval it's
called socket.repeat and inside that we
are calling socket.send info and we're
passing in just a tick event and that
basically is kicking off the handle info
event every time that handle info event
runs it's just pulling in random data in
this case it could obviously be pulling
in your actual data
and then the the render life cycle runs
and and your page gets updated
cool
um let's talk about type annotations so
I I'm a typescript developer I love
typescript I like when libraries help me
help myself
and so in in live view JS we actually
you know highly recommend you write your
code in typescripts you can take
advantage of typescript
in this case I'm sharing a couple
examples where you can pass in the type
annotations into the create live view
function so this is how you create a
live view just a helper function
in the first example you're kind of like
inlining the types for there's three
different types you can pass in one is
the context right the shape of your
state the second one is the the set of
events that you can that you expect to
come into your your handle info method
and the third is the set of infos right
the kind of server events that you
expect to come into your handle info so
in the top case we're just doing it in
line you know here's the shape of our
contacts we're expecting one refresh
type event coming into handle event and
one tick event coming to handle info the
second example is just you can Define
your types elsewhere right you can
Define some other types above and then
just you know pass those types directly
into the type annotation as well so I
don't know if you're a typescript geek
or not but we try to make it easy the
next this this next slide is just
showing you here's a case of like you
are making some you know the typescript
compiler points out errors when in your
code when if if you actually provide us
with type annotations
so the the first case
you know on line 12 you can see the
little squiggly maybe underline but
we've defined our the shape of our
contacts to the account with that's a
number
um and in line 12 we're trying to assign
my count uh property to that to the
socket that's not going to work
typescript tells us the other example
again it's a little hard to see sorry
but line 24 we're trying to look for a
type called reset as a hand event coming
in we haven't defined that type in our
type annotations Above So typescript
tells us you're doing something wrong so
just wanted to say this is a you know
library that tries to help you write
better code
and you know by providing types and type
annotations to your uh to your live view
we can help point out you know problems
you might have
cool
it's going great
um
first first public talk
uh all right
user events and bindings
there's four types of the more main main
types of user events that kind of the
bread and butter of live view live VJs
there's clicks forms keyboard input and
there's Focus blur events
there's some other bindings and sort of
like things you can you can do with pass
in with these events there's value
bindings there's rate limiting bindings
we can actually throttle and de-bounce
really easily in live view live VJs so
you know I'm not going to cover that
today but a ton of ton of documentation
a lot of you liveujs.com
um so let's let's first start on um well
so those are the types of events in
order to to capture those events you
need to annotate your HTML with these
bindings which are also known as
attributes
so add you know in order to add uh
basically you can add any of these
bindings I'll go over a few in a minute
here to your HTML elements when those
element when those events happen the
live view JS Library automatically
recognizes that and then ships those
events up to your up to your server
um so super basic but this is how the
click happens uh on on you know through
that first
dark background there we've got a button
it's annotated with the pH x dash click
uh binding or or attribute and the the
value of that attribute is set to
increment so that just means when a
click happens I'm going to ship an event
called increment up to my server
okay
um
the the PHX part of this comes from
Phoenix live view so again I mentioned
this earlier we are totally built on top
of this amazing you know Library battle
tested library that Phoenix ships so we
didn't reinvent the wheel we're just
using theirs and by default all of their
attributes are our prefix with PHX you
can easily change it it's something
that's a you know changeable I just went
with the defaults but um just wanted to
point that out thank you Phoenix live
view people
um
and when you know again when that click
when that click event happens your
handle event method will receive this
you know this to Json payload
uh key events right so you want to
capture keyboard events uh this is an
example of of uh a div where
if your key down key down you press the
key down on the Arrow up button sorry I
probably should have had a better
example here but um
uh that's what this this first dark
background example shows is when you hit
the arrow up button basically that key
event will be shipped to your handle
event method
along with the arrow up
key that you pressed
so you can filter out by key PHX key or
you can just capture all the key events
and then filter them in your server if
you want
um
so that's how that works
pretty straightforward
I think you know maybe another battery
is included like
actually capturing key events is pretty
nice and easy you just annotate your
your HTML all right
battery included forms and change sets
I'm excited about this one
change that's amazing
all right we'll get there in a minute
first there are two form bindings only
two bindings for forms there's a PHX
Dash change binding and a PHX Dash
submit binding okay change is when any
form input is updated in your form
and you can
to be clear you can like rate limit that
so if you want to capture just when
someone stops typing for a second I'll
actually show you that later on so it
doesn't have to send every event but um
so when any form of that is updated PHX
change that's called whatever event is
passed to your your server
PHX submit is probably obvious when your
form is submitted it sends an event to
your server both of those events also
get all of the form input data that are
that are part of your form so you don't
have to do anything about your you know
to send that data it's automatically all
all shipped up there for you
uh cool so here's some code
um first first uh
window there is again you're just
annotating a form with PHX change the
exact PHX submit when change happens a
validated event is going to be sent with
all of your form data when submit
happens a save event is going to be
shipped with all of your form data and
then you can do what you need to and
I'll show you change stats here in a
minute but typically you're you know on
the change event you're validating your
form right and on the save event you're
validating and doing whatever you need
to do and mutating your data
cool
all right change sets again stolen
directly from Phoenix live view I think
this is Gene it might be actually Ecto
which is their uh their kind of data
library but it's completely imported
from them and I I don't know of anything
in the you know JavaScript ecosystem
that I think is as cool so
um highly recommend this part of you
know really everything but this is
pretty cool
what it does it allows you to map data
basically map form and data a model
between your form and back so
automatically does that parsing and
mapping and error checking connects it
to your form automatically shows errors
when your forms invalid I'll show you an
example it's built on top of this
amazing typescript Library called Zod I
don't know if anyone's familiar with
design but it's amazing we it's one of
the only dependencies that we we built
on top of because it really drives this
feature
Zod is a typescript for schema
validation Library which
uh it's super easy to learn and I'll
show you some code you'll you'll be
experts as well
whatever beginners at least in one
minute
um and again this is like designed to
work directly with form so it makes
mapping data between forms and data
models super easy
um
cool let's let's show let's let's look
at some code all right this is uh this
is just a little baby form
but it's uh imagine I have like my
library and I want to you know put all
my my books in the you know in the
library so here I'm going to do The
Hobbit
and obviously that's
oh I hit enter too soon boom we've got
our validation coming back saying hey
this must contain four characters I'll
show you the code in a second
uh so I need
so I am also debouncing this so after I
stop typing for one second it'll
automatically try to validate again so
I'm just going to type JRR
and you should see
oh four characters right
huh there we go so stop typing it
automatically sent the
um
called the the pH exchange event and set
it up to my server for validation so
finish uh that's not how you spell it
so there we go now I've um my form was
automatically validated when I hit
submit the save event was called same
validation functions were run and
automatically well not automatically say
but then I could continue on with my
life
okay I'm going to close this
cool
so here's the code this is just the kind
of defining the schema first and the
change set itself
so pretty straightforward we've got this
book schema
right it's an this is this is the Zod
part you have an object it's got these
four properties ID name author checked
out which you saw uh ID is just by
default gonna be a random string
checkdown is by default going to be
false and then name an author you can
see we've got a couple of uh
kind of constraints there these name
needs to be at least two characters up
to a hundred author needs to be four
characters up 200. there's a lot of
other validations you can do in Zod
email phone number all that stuff's
built in
um and this will all work with with any
of those configurations
we after we Define that schema schema is
basically what's what Zod parses to turn
your Json data into uh or the Json data
to validate it against that schema we're
also going to infer the book type which
is just helpful in in typing our change
set so the last line here is this new
change that factory live VJs function so
we're going to pass in the schema we're
going to type it as a book so now we
have this change that factory for a book
and we're going to use that to do our
validation and form
kind of submission
code in the next in the next section
uh cool
so here is
um
this is the render function so this is
how the form gets rendered back or
rendered in in your live view again a
little hard to see but you can see we've
got a couple of helpers here form for uh
online I don't have this numbered
of some reason
or is my thing Okay so we've got a form
for helper here we've got our PHX submit
and change
events defined
here we've got a text input this is
where the change that part comes in
we've got a text input we're passing in
a change set for that book that change
that has whether that that particular
well has all the data about the full
model and then using the name
um property it's going to look up the
the name data whether it's valid or not
and sort of set that back to the to the
text input the error tag will only
render if there's a valid error at that
property there's a lot of cool
typescript stuff in the back back and
background here but this is this is how
easy it is to connect your change that
to a form you can see this is the PHX
the bounce part I was telling me about
so after I stopped typing for one second
this automatically knows only send the
form field or only send a PHX change
event once this input has been to bounce
for a second
um then we got our you know we got our
author uh field as well and then we've
got our submit button
so that's
that's pretty straightforward code
um
this is the handle event method right
again every user event goes back to
handle event in this case these are the
you know cut a little bit of code out
here but these are the validate method
or event that's called when PHX change
happens and the save event when PHX
submit happens and the first part line
basically five six seven
uh all we're doing is
just using this book change set Factory
we're passing in the event data which
has all of the form field data
automatically and we've defined that
we've actually defined that type
elsewhere but it's already automatically
part of that event
and we're setting the change set data
back into the context so basically when
all those validation errors occur that's
the one line that we're calling to show
validation errors to our users which is
pretty sweet
uh and then the save method uh or say
you know save event here
it's a little bit more a little bit more
work we're just checking to see on line
13 if that change that is valid if it is
cool let's save that book add it to our
database
and then clear the form that's what the
kind of line 18 does just resets our
change set
and if it's not valid we're just going
to pass back that that change that and
make people fix their errors
so that's how the basically that's how
easy it is to
add
um
form validation and change that to your
to your live view
all right awesome latest is what I I
wrote this a little while back we've got
file uploads now the batteries included
feature
um
it's pretty sweet we've got automatic
image previews upload progress drag and
drop support
and you know constraints
so what file types you want to limit
people to upload file size the number of
files that they can upload all that
stuff
pretty I'll I'll really easy to set
all right demo time
cool so
uh here is our photo groups app
we've got uh we've got some files here
that I've already kind of pre-loaded so
in this case
uh oh actually I should show you first
um
the constraints so in our in our photo
group app we only want to limit up to
three photos to be uploaded at a time
with a Max of five megabyte per photo
and it's also
photos so it'll only allow image uploads
so that's that's kind of what we've got
here let's say I don't know I want to
upload a kitten
here's my image preview for that cat
I've got the progress bar which we
haven't uploaded the image yet got a
little remove image if we want so I can
click that and that image goes away
so all this is is you know built in
pretty easily let's go back to our cats
and look at fluffy
let's try to get five files uploaded
here
and see what happens
all right so we got a couple errors here
got too many files and we've got
something that's too large
so this happens to be a file of my dog
which is larger than five megabytes
so we can't upload that one so we're
gonna remove it we still have too many
files you can see all that's updated
automatically
so I'm going to take this first [ __ ] cat
I think and just remove that and now you
can see our errors have gone away
um I'm going to try some in this and see
what happens
all right so all of our imagers images
all the image data has actually been
uploaded but we still had a validation
error we need at least one
you know one character in our photo grip
name so let's let's name that
fluffy nope fluffy
uh and then we should be able to
upload finish our stuff cool all of our
files are now validated or our form was
validated so we can actually take those
files process them and now in this case
we're just re-rendering the you know the
photo group back out at you with some
numbers
but that's how that's
I'm going to show you some code that's
going to be how easy
it is to do that
all right cool
so constraints right so we talked about
limitations on the number of entries the
number of the file size and the file
type so that's all in this up allow
upload socket function here we're we're
basically naming our upload config as
photos which we use kind of Elsewhere
and then setting the file type
extensions we can also support mine
types but setting the file type
extensions here to a set of photos that
we want images that we want to allow
I've got three files maximum for upload
and then our Max file size is five
megabytes and all that data is actually
passed in back into your render function
so you can update your uh your HTML as
you know if you're if your constraints
change it'll automatically you could
automatically upload your HTML
all right how we doing on time we've got
about 10 minutes so I'm going to rush
through a couple of things
okay
a quick image preview example
so this is how the image previews Works
we've got our meta in our render
function we have this meta object we're
getting our uploads from that and we're
going to map through the entries and
call this render entry helper function
and inside that align 13 you've got this
helper tag called live image preview
passing your entry and that just renders
your your preview image so it's
literally one tag to get image previews
uh this is the upload progress so again
it's um
we're getting our uploads object from
our meta
our meta object that's passed into
render we're going to get our photos out
of that and the entries out of that map
over those and then each entry
automatically has a has a progress
property and as the progress as those
files get uploaded the progress gets
updated and you can update your your UI
so it's really simple in this case we're
just showing a progress meter
and you know outputting the percentage
of progress so far
drag and drop also a one-liner or less
than one liner in this case line five
we've got this PHX drop Target
with uh and we're passing in the uploads
photos ref that's it just turns your div
into a draggable Target and
automatically knows what uh what upload
config to
um to put your entries into
so just like how could it be easier than
that I just don't know
um
cool all right last topic
and then we'll do some questions so
real-time multiplayer batteries included
we natively support real-time
multiplayer user experiences it's built
on top of Pub sub Primitives
we've got so there's like minimal effort
by you
um there's basically three type of Pub
sub implementations uh depending on your
run time so there's always like a single
process Pub sub that's just kind of
basic testing local stuff we also have a
redis pub sub implementation for node.js
and we have a broadcast channels
implementation for Dino so if you're
into Dino or you understand you know
it's actually a really cool part of Dino
deploy where broadcast channels is
actually a kind of a global topic queue
that you can post messages to and get
And subscribe to so that's where built
on top of
and there's
you know there's really two things that
you know that enable all real-time Pub
sub stuff which is one uh broadcast uh
which is the method that you uh
essentially call from your Pub sub
implementation to push messages to a
topic whatever Json top or message you
want to you want to publish and then
subscribe is how you subscribe to
messages from that topic and those
messages always get pushed to your
handle info method that we saw before
and so that's basically how it works
super easy
uh and really powerful
the the framework automatically sort of
you know manages all the routing stuff
for you so once you've hit you've
subscribed in your socket to a topic
live VJs will make sure it gets there
um assuming you know it's it's obviously
if you're running multi-process you need
to be using one of the multi-process
implementations
but that's how it works
all right so I've actually showed you
um
some real time
examples already so let's let's do this
all right I'm going to pull this one
down
and then
okay so we've got
we basically have you know two uh two
tabs they're both loading the same live
view I don't know why you'd need a
counter that's real time multiplayer but
here's here's a real-time multiplayer
counter and I'll show you the code
actually I'll show you the other
examples first and then I'll show you
all the code okay uh so you guys
let's close that one actually
all right
it's annoying going back and forth but
uh we'll get we'll get there
okay
so we saw the my library my library kind
of example as well
um here you can see where I'm just gonna
check out this book
and it's automatically updated in the
other uh live view
so pretty straightforward we got another
book Foo or
uh oh right it needs to be four
characters
uh there you go we added a new book
automatically got pushed to both both
tabs
um
and let's do one more
which is our
photos
uh okay
oops
um so in this one
we'll choose some more files
oh yeah that one's too big sorry
it's hard to see over here
oh well whatever
um
cool and you can see we you know those
get uploaded as well so
all right I know we're running out of
time so I'll uh I'll speed this up
um that's that's actually pretty much it
so you know for the you know just
real-time Sock It Up subscribe we've got
this uh topic that we've now subscribed
to called counter and then we're going
to publish uh broadcast counter events
in the in the handle event method for
books same thing we've got a socket that
subscribes to the books topic and then
publishes uh I know I'm going fast here
but publishes the events back using
broadcast to the books topic with the
with the type updated and then the
handle event
um updates the example so that's how
easy it is to do a multi-player
real-time stuff there's lots of other
topics that I did not have time to get
through which are all available online
uh lots of cool stuff there's actually a
live view native project now you can do
live views in iOS we have live
components lots of other life cycle
stuff
security so I know we're out of time but
um I do want to say thank you to the
strangeloop organizers awesome thanks
for having me thank you all for
listening to my first public talk
hopefully it didn't go too bad and
thanks special thanks to Larry for nerd
sniping me into labviewjs
uh if you want to learn more happy to
talk there's also there's like 25 000
lines of documentation or words of
documentation on livevjs.com that I
wrote
um would love to answer any questions
there's a couple of Socials on there to
follow as well
um any questions real quick
yeah great question it's actually one of
the topics I didn't get to we have this
thing called a JS command which is part
of uh live it's actually part of the
live view new release that came out for
Phoenix as well but it allows you to
Define transitions transition classes
that you want to make and Target
specific Dom elements
it also has a bunch of kind of utilities
for like hiding different dominoes
showing them toggling between them so
there's the JS commands is what you're
looking for happy dish
uh it gets shipped along with the diff
yep yeah with your event yeah and it's
yeah it's okay go ahead
oh yeah
I haven't I'm not familiar with Caldera
so I don't know uh the question was how
different how is it different than
Caldera I I just I don't know maybe I
should check that out
do you have an answer to that
yeah
[Music]
I would I would guess I would be I'd
wonder if any of them are compliant to
the actual live view sort of spec right
um are they reusing the same library
that Phoenix live view is uh I don't
know next question
[Music]
or whatever
in terms of long sessions and like oh
the version of the server like yep
like how do you not have a step change
or like lose user state or is is
about a versioning
it smoothly or is it left as an exercise
yeah that's a good question um so all
estate is always on your server so
assuming that you're actually you know
saving the state on your server updates
should not shouldn't really matter
theoretically you could run into like an
impedance mismatch right where you like
have the server with different events
event handling or you're renaming stuff
so yeah I don't know I haven't run I'm
like this is so new I haven't run into
that yet but I think it's a really
interesting question
it could yeah
yeah
all whatever you want right so you want
to use Tailwind great you want to you
know do your own CSS and it's all just
HTML so however you want to apply uh you
know CSS your HTML that's how you do it
okay we're we're out of time thank you
so much
I would love to answer any more
questions